Samsung a sorti deux versions de son S23
une version en 128 Go de stockage une
version en 256 Go de stockage sauf qu'il
y a une grosse différence technique
entre ces deux modèles je vous explique
c'est à dire que la version 128 est bien
vous êtes sur une ancienne technologie
de stockage c'est de l'UFS 3.1 tandis
que sur la version 256 et sur l'ensemble
des autres modèles vous êtes en ufs 4.0
ça change vraiment tout parce que l'UFS
4.0 et 2 fois plus rapide ce qui fait
que vous aurez des traitements qui
seront beaucoup mieux lorsque vous allez
jouer à des jeux ça ira beaucoup plus
vite sera toujours plus fluide lorsque
vous allez venir enregistrer des vidéos
ça sera beaucoup plus fluide et en plus
de ça le fs4.0 va venir jouer dans
l'autonomie de votre Smartphone vous
allez moins consommer au niveau de la
batterie donc ce qui faut retenir ici
c'est que si vous prenez sur le Galaxy
S23 et uniquement sur le Galaxy S23 un
stockage en 128 Go et bien vous aura un
smartphone qui sera en réalité moins
performant que la version en 256 Go ce
que vous le saviez oui non pas comment
d'ailleurs j'en ai déjà parlé sur
Youtube dites-le-moi en bas dans les
commentaires